well before we even knew what dna was
much less how it was structured or was
replicated or even before we could look
in and and see meiosis happening in
cells we had the general sense that
offspring were the products of some
traits that their parents had that you
know if i had a a a guy with blue eyes
let me say this is the
blue eyed guy right here
and then if he were to uh marry a a
brown hot eyed girl
let's say this is the brown eyed girl
maybe make it a little bit more like a
girl
if he were to marry the brown eyed girl
there that most of the time or maybe in
all cases where we're dealing with the
brown eyed girl maybe their their kids
are brown-eyed
let me do so they have a little
brown-eyed
baby here
all right and this is just something i
mean there's obviously thousands of
generations of human beings and we've
observed this we've observed that kids
look like their parents that they
inherit some traits and that some traits
seem to dominate other traits and one
example of that tends to be a darker
pigmentation and maybe the hair or the
eyes even if the other
if the other parent has light
pigmentation the darker one seems to
dominate or sometimes it actually ends
up being a mix and we've seen that all
around us now this study of what gets
passed on and how it gets passed on it's
much older than the study of dna which
was really kind of discovered in the
or became a big deal in the middle of
the 20th century this was studied a long
time and kind of the the father of
classical genetics and heredity is
gregor
mendel gregor
mendel who's actually a monk and he
would mess around with with plants and
across them and see which traits got
passed and which traits didn't get
passed and try to get understanding of
of how how traits are passed from one
generation to another so when we do this
when we study these this you know i'll
call it classical
classical genetics i'm going to make a
bunch of simplifying assumptions and
because we know that most of these don't
hold for most of our genes
but give us a little bit of sense of how
to predict what might happen in in in
future in future generations so the
first simplifying assumption i'll make
is that is that
some traits have kind of this all or
nothing property
and we know that a lot of traits don't
that let's say that they're in the world
and this is a gross over simplification
let's say for eye color
eye color
let's say that there are two alleles now
remember what an allele was an allele is
a specific version of a gene
so let's say that there's the you could
have blue eye color
or you could have brown eye color
or you could have brown eyed color that
we lived in the universe where someone
could only have one of these two
versions of the eye color gene we know
that eye color is far more complex than
that so this is just a simplification
and let me just make up another one let
me say that um i don't know maybe a uh
for for for teeth for tooth size
tooth size
that's a trait you won't see in any
traditional biology textbook and let's
say that there's one trait for big teeth
big teeth and that there's another
allele for small teeth
small teeth and i want to make very
clear this distinction between a gene
and an allele
allele so let's let's you know i i
talked about gregor mendel and he was
doing this in the 1850s well before we
knew what dna was or how or what even
chromosomes were and how dna was passed
on and et cetera etc
but
let's think a little bit about let's go
into the into the into the microbiology
of it to understand the difference so i
have a chromosome
let's say on some chromosome let me pick
a
let me pick some chromosome here is it
say this is some chromosome let's say i
got that from my dad and on this
chromosome
there's some location here we could call
that the locus on this chromosome that
where the eye color gene is
that's the location of the eye color
gene now i have two chromosomes one from
my father and one from my mother so
let's say that this is the chromosome
from my mother
and that you know we know that when
they're normally in the cell they aren't
nice and neatly organized like this in a
chromosome but this is just to kind of
show you the idea and let's say these
are homologous chromosomes so they code
for the same genes so on this gene from
my mother on that same location or locus
there is also
the eye color gene
now i might have the same the same
version of the gene and i'm saying that
there's only two versions of this gene
in the world now if i have the same
version of the gene i'm going to make a
little shorthand notation i'm going to
write big b
actually let me do it the other way i'm
going to write little b for blue and i'm
going to write big b for brown
this if i there's a situation where this
could be a
little b and this could be a big b
and then i could write that my genotype
my genotype i have the allele i have one
big b for my mom and i have one small b
for my
dad
each of these instances or or
ways that this gene is expressed is an
allele so this is so these are two
different alleles
let me write that
two
different
alleles or versions of the same gene and
when i have two different versions like
this one version from my mom one version
from my dad
i'm called a heterozygote or sometimes
it's called a heterozygose genotype
heterozygose zygus
genotype and the genotype is the exact
versions of the alleles i have if i had
let's say in i had uh the the lower case
b i had the
the blue eye gene from both parents so
let's say that i was
lowercase b lowercase b
then i would have two identical alleles
both of my parents gave me the same
version of the gene and in this case
i'm called
this this genotype is homozygous
zyg
or this is a homozygous genotype or i'm
a homozygote for this trait
homozygous now you might say sal this is
fine these are the traits that you have
this case you know i have a
a brown from
maybe my mom
and a blue from my dad in this case i
have a blue from both my mom and dad
how do we know whether my eyes are going
to be brown or blue
and the reality is is it's very complex
that it's just a whole mixture of things
but mendel he studied things that uh
that ex that that showed what we'll call
dominance
and this is the idea
that one of these traits dominates the
other so a lot of people originally
thought that eye color especially blue
eyes was a was always dominated by the
other trait so we'll assume that here
but that's a gross oversimplification so
let's say that brown eyes are dominant
brown eyes brown are dominant
and blue are recessive
blue
i wanted to do that in blue
and blue eyes
blue eyes are recessive
if this is the case and this is a as
i've said repeatedly this is a gross
oversimplification but if that is the
case then if i were to inherit
this genotype
because brown eyes are dominant remember
i said the big b
the big b here represents brown eyes you
won't and the the lower case b is
recessive all you're going to see
all you're going to see for the person
with this genotype is brown eyes
so let me do this here let me write this
here so genotype
genotype
and then i'll write phenotype and
genotype is the actual versions of the
gene you have and then the phenotypes
are what's expressed or what do you see
so phenotype
so if i get a brown eyed jean from my
dad i like doing this a big i want to do
it in brown let me do it in brown so you
don't get confused
so if i have a
brown eye gene for my
dad and a blue-eyed gene from my mom
my color transitions aren't
there a blue-eyed gene from my mom
because the brown eye is recessed the
brown eyed allele is recessive and i
just said a brown eyed gene but what i
should say is the brown eyed version of
the gene which is the brown allele or
the blue-eyed version of the gene for my
mom which is the blue allele since the
brown allele is dominant i wrote that up
here
what's going to be expressed are brown
eyes
brown
now if i have let's say i have let's say
if i had it the other way let's say i
got a blue eyed from my dad and i get a
blue-eyed allele from my dad and i get a
brown eyed allele from my mom
same thing the phenotype is going to be
brown eyes
now what if i get a brown eyed allele
from both my mom and my dad
let me see i keep changing the shade of
brown but they're all supposed to be the
same so let's say i get two dominant
brown eyed alleles from my mom and my
dad then what are you going to see well
you could guess that i'm still going to
see
brown eyes
brown eyes so there's only one last
combination because these are the only
two types of alleles we might see in our
population although for most genes
there's more than two types for example
there's you know blood types there's a
there's multiple there's four types of
blood
but let's say that i get two
blue from each of one blue allele from
each of my parents
one from my dad one from my mom
then all of a sudden this is a recessive
trait but there's nothing to dominate it
so all of a sudden the phenotype will be
blue eyes and i want to repeat again
this isn't necessarily
how the alleles for eye color work but
it's a nice simplification to to maybe
understand
how heredity works and there are some
traits that do that that can be studied
in this simple way but what i wanted to
do here is to show you that
many different genotypes so these are
all different genotypes they all coded
for the same phenotype so just by
looking at someone's eye color you
didn't even you didn't know exactly
whether they were homozygous dominant
this would be
homozygous dominant
or whether they were heterozygotes
this is heterozygous right here these
two right here
are heterozygotes
heterozygotes
are also
sometimes called as hybrids but the word
hybrid is kind of overloaded it's used a
lot but in this context it means that
you got
different versions of the allele for
that for that gene
so let's think a little bit about what's
actually happening when um when when my
mom and my dad reproduced
so my dad well let's let's think of a
couple of different scenarios let's say
my dad was
let's say that they're both hybrids my
dad has
has the brown eye dominant allele
and he also has
he also has the blue eyed recessive
allele and let's say my mom has the same
thing so brown eyed dominant and she
also has the blue-eyed recessive allele
now let's think about if if these two
people before you see what my eye color
is if you said look i'm giving you what
these two people's genotypes are and let
me label them this is
the well i mean i could make let me make
this the mom i think this is the
standard convention
and let's make this right here this is
the dad
this is the dad what are the different
genotypes that their children could have
so let's say they reproduce
what i'm going to i'm going to draw a
little grid here
so let me draw a grid
all right
so we know from our study of meiosis
that look my mom
my mom has this gene on let me let me
draw the genes again
so there's a homologous pair
right this is one gene right here one
chromosome right here that's another
chromosome right there on this
chromosome in the homologous pair there
might be the
at that at the
eye color locus
there's the brown eye gene and at this
one at the eye color locus there's a
blue eye gene
and similarly for my dad when you look
at that same
chromosome in his cells
let me do them like this so this is one
chromosome there and this is the other
chromosome here
when you look at that locus on this
chromosome or that location it has the
brown-eyed allele for that gene and on
this one it has the blue-eyed allele on
this gene and we learn from meiosis when
the chromosomes well they replicate
first and so you have these you know two
chromatids on a chromosome but they line
up in meiosis one during the metaphase
and we don't know which way they line up
for example my dad might give me this
chromosome or might give me that
chromosome or my mom might give me that
chromosome so i could have any of these
combinations so for example if i get
this chromosome from my mom and this
chromosome from my dad what is the
genotype going to be for eye color well
it's going to be
capital b and capital b what's if i get
this
chromosome from my mom and this
chromosome from my dad what's it going
to be well i'm going to get the
i'm going to get the the big b
from my dad and then i'm going to get
the lowercase b from my mom so this is
another possibility
now this is this is another possibility
here where i get the with the brown eyed
allele for my mom
from my mom and i get the blue eye
allele from my dad and then there is a
possibility that i get this chromosome
from my dad and this chromosome from my
mom so it's this situation
now what are the phenotypes going to be
well we've already seen that this one
right here is going to this one's going
to be brown
that one's going to be brown this one's
going to be brown
but this one is going to be blue i
already showed you this
but if i were to tell you ahead of time
that look i have two people they're both
hybrids or they're both heterozygotes
for eye color and eye color is has
expressed has this recessive dominant
situation and they're both heterozygotes
where they have each have one
brown allele and one blue allele and
they're going to have a child what's the
probability that the child has brown
eyes
brown
what's the probability
well each of these scenarios are equally
likely right there's four equal
scenarios so let's put that in the
denominator four equal scenarios and how
many of those scenarios end up with
brown eyes well it's one two three
so the probability is three-fourths or
it's a 75 percent probability
75 percent probability same logic what's
the probability that these parents
produce an offspring with blue eyes
well that's only one of the four equally
likely possibilities so blue eyes
blue eyes is
is only 25
now what is the probability that they
produce a heterozygote so what is the
probability that they produce a a
heterozygous offspring
heterozygous so now we're not looking at
the phenotype anymore we're looking at
the genotype so of these combinations
which are heterozygous
well this one is because it has a mix
it's a hybrid it has a mix of the two
alleles and so is this one so what's the
probability well there's four different
combinations all of those are equally
likely and two of them result in a
heterozygote so it's two-fourths or
one-half or
fifty percent
so using this punnett square and of
course we have to make a lot of
assumptions about the genes and
whether one's dominant or ones are
recessive we can start to make
predictions about the probabilities of
of different outcomes and as we'll see
in future videos you can actually even
go backwards you can say hey given that
this couple had five kids with brown
eyes what's the probability that uh
they're both uh heterozygotes or
something like that so it's a really
interesting area even though it is a bit
of oversimplification but many traits
especially some of the things that that
gregor or mendel studied can be studied
in this way